time for your friday morning shot of
adrenaline when you think of sailing you
might not think of extreme action hair
raising speed or death defying crashes a
new racing league called sail gp is
trying to change the way you look at the
sport this weekend it hosts the grand
finale of its season with a series of
races in the san francisco bay that's
where cbs sunday morning correspondent
lee cowan boarded a 50-foot catamaran to
shot off and shut off at speeds of
almost 60 miles per hour
[Music]
up on land she looks a bit awkward long
and wide her lines more aggressive than
graceful
but
once in the water
the f50 catamaran is a rock capable of
sailing yes sailing
up to 60 miles an hour on these boats
you can't just sort of go half speed it
just has to be full throttle or nothing
like hesitation is actually very
dangerous in these boats they don't so
much float as fly on whiskers of carbon
fiber that curl beneath the hull
that lift the boat straight out of the
water it's called foiling a new class of
boat for a new breed of sailor it's fun
who wants to go slide
you know
australian jimmy spithill is a legend
and this one is for all the marbles he
was the architect of one of the biggest
sailing comebacks in america's cup
history back in
2013. america's cop will stay in america
but before these boats came along some
of his fellow athletes and friends
wondered why he'd even bother with a
sport that can be to a non-sailor at
least like watching paint dry as soon as
they started watching this they were
like man what the hell have you guys
been doing all these years this is
freaking awesome this is made for tv and
that is the point of sale gp a new
league founded in 2018 by larry ellison
chairman of oracle and leader of five
america's cup campaigns himself
now in its second season sale gp has
eight boats representing eight countries
crewed by some of the best sailors in
the world all hoping to bring the sport
of sailing out of the doldrums and into
a class
with formula one racing but it's gonna
be tommy
in the old format
we used to race for an hour and a half
sometimes three hours sometimes the race
wouldn't finish it'd be so slow
veteran sailor russell coops is the ceo
now when you think about it our final
race is 15 minutes and so that's very
very geared towards the modern
viewership habits it says a lot about
our attention span these days right
there is certainly an element of science
fiction all this so much so director
christopher nolan put the flying cats on
the big screen in his movie tennis
that kind of mainstream visibility is
attracting younger faces to the sport as
well
at only 18 cj perez is the first and the
youngest female sailor to join the sail
gp roster women are just as talented
we're just as skillful as these men
we need to join in with them and create
a more diverse environment for everybody
how competitive are you
i am so competitive i can't even tell
you
this is our time to win we are working
so hard it's guns blazing but blazingly
fast votes can bite too
kind of the harder you push the faster
you go
but you cross that line there's going to
be a crash look at the british boat leap
out of the water in sydney last year the
japanese lost their bow after the boat
from great britain sliced it off in a
collision look at the load there in
denmark the us boat came around so fast
it threw crewman paul campbell james
clear out of his cockpit he broke his
leg i will say he continued to finish
the race and then got off went to
hospital and got his lair car so serious
yeah that that's the sort of attitude
that's in the team
up and away that's all to say you better
not bring your chardonnay aboard getting
on the water with the us team is like
joining any cool club there's a bit of
hazing it's nice and easy just keep in
mind
that was how they teach you what to do
if you fall off the boat and get trapped
under it
even to a train die it looks more like a
mob hit than a safety demo
but boy is it effective
i took one of the six coveted spots on
the crew which made me feel more like a
third wheel on a date all right let's
get it
the athleticism of the sailors around me
running and grinding sometimes against
three g's or more of force
was as humbling as it was remarkable
they even sound like a fighter jet they
go so fast which has a lot of old salts
wondering if this
is really sailing at all
it's totally serious it's you've got the
feel of the wind the salt spray on your
face and everything and yet you times
all of that by like 100.
beautiful it's fast it's dangerous it's
scary
everything you want in sport right
all this high-tech on the high seas
doesn't mean the age-old art of
harnessing the wind is gone it just
means you can now fly like the wind to
catch it for cbs mornings i'm lee cow
somewhere in the san francisco bay
somewhere in the san francisco bay and
lee's okay i think that is so cool it's
very cool and i i like the
technology
is that your way of saying no i mean i
want to go to space but this seems more
in my mind this seems more dangerous
yeah and i'm not an adrenaline junkie at
all no no absolutely not but i do i
think i'd go for it i watch you i want
to do it for a living
i think nate is volunteering for an
assignment i would like to see that i'd
really like all right i'll be watching
that too thank you lee cowan